hi everyone and welcome to lecture nine
for CS 2:30 today we're going to discuss
an advanced topic that will be kind of
the marriage between deep learning and
another field of AI which is
reinforcement learning and we will see a
practical application and how deep
learning methods can be plugged in
another family of algorithm so it's
interesting because deep learning
methods and deep inner networks have
been shown to be very good function
approximate errs essentially that's what
they are we're giving them data so that
they can approximate a function there
are a lot of different fields which
require these function approximate errs
and deep learning methods can be plugged
in all these methods this is one of
these examples so we'll first motivate
the setting of reinforcement learning
why do we need your enforcement learning
why cannot what why can't we use deep
learning methods to solve everything
there is some set of methods that we
cannot solve with deep learning and
reinforcement learning that
reinforcement learning applications are
examples of that we will see an example
to introduce an algorithm of real for
smuggling algorithm called cue learning
and we will add deep learning to this
algorithm and make it deep cue learning
as we've seen with generative add
virtual networks and also deep neural
networks most models are hard to train
with how we had to come up with the
initialization we drop out with batch
norm and mirrors mirrors of methods to
make this deep neural networks trained
in gans we had to use methods as well in
order to train guns and tricks and hacks
so here we will see some of the tips and
tricks to train deep cue learning which
is a reinforcement learning algorithm
and at the end we will have a guest
speaker coming to talk about advanced
topics which are mostly research which
buying deep learning and reinforcement
learning sounds good okay let's go so
different force malaria is a very recent
field I would say although both things
are our enforcement ring has existed for
a long time only recently it's been
shown that using deep learning as a way
to approximate the functions that play a
big role in reinforcement learning
algorithms has worked a lot so one
example is alphago and you probably all
have heard of it it's google deepmind's
alphago has beaten world champions in a
game called the game of Go which is a
very very old strategy old game and the
one on the right here or on your right
human level controlled through deep
reinforcement learning is also a deep
mind a google deepmind paper that came
out and hit the headlines on the front
page of nature which is a one of the
leading multi disciplinary peer-reviewed
journals in the world and they've shown
that with deep learning plugged in a
reinforcement learning setting they can
train an agent that beats human level in
a variety of games and in fact these are
Atari games so they've shown actually
that their algorithm the same algorithm
reproduced for a large number of games
can beat humans on all of these games
most of these games not all of these so
these are two examples although they use
different sub techniques of
reinforcement learning they both include
some deep learning aspect in it and
today we will mostly talk about the
human level control through deep
reinforcement learning also called deep
cue Network presented in this paper so
let's start with with motivating
reinforcement learning using the the
alphago setting this is a board of goal
and the picture comes from deep mind
block so go you can think of it as a
strategy game where you have a grid that
is up to 19 by 19 and you have two
players one player has white stones and
one player has black stones
and at every step in the game you can
position a stone on the on the board on
one of the grid cross the goal is to
surround your opponent so to maximize
your territory by surrounding your
opponent and it's a very complex game
for different reasons
one reason is that you have to be you
cannot be short-sighted in this game you
have to have a long term strategy and
other reason is that the board is so big
it's much bigger than a chess board
right chess board is 8 by 8 so let me
ask you a question if you had to solve
or build an agent that solves this game
and beats humans or plays very well at
least with deep learning methods that
you've seen so far how would you do that
someone wants to try so let's say you
have a you have to collect the data set
because in classic supervised learning
we need a data set with X&Y
what do you think would be your x and y
yeah okay
input is game board and output is
probability of victory in that position
so that's that's a good one I think
input output what's the issue with that
one so yeah it's super hard to represent
what the probability of winning is from
this boy even like nobody can tell even
if I ask an expert human to come and
tell us what's the probability of black
winning in this or white winning in this
setting they wouldn't be able to tell so
this is a little more complicated any
other ideas of data sets yep
okay good point so we could have the
grid like this one and then this is the
input and the output would be the move
the next action taken by probably a
professional player so we would just
watch professional players playing and
we would record their moves and we would
build a data set of what is a
professional move and we hope that our
network using this input-output will at
some point learn how the professional
players play and given an input state of
the board we'll be able to decide of the
next move what's the issue with that
[Music]
yes you need a whole lot of data why and
you said it you said because we need
basically to represent all types of
positions of the board all states so if
you were actually let's let's do that if
we were to compute the number of
possible states of this board what would
it be so 19 by 19 word
remember what we did with adversarial
examples we did it for pixel's right now
we're doing it for a board so what's the
question first is yes you want to try
yeah 3 to the power 9 10 times 90 or 93
yeah so why is it that is it yeah each
spot and there are 19 times 19 spots can
have 3 state basically no stone white
stone or black stone so this is the all
possible state this is about 10 to the
117 so it's super super big so we can
probably not get even close to that by
observing professional players first
because we don't have enough Pro
shelters and because we're humans and we
don't have infinite life so the
professional players cannot play forever
they might get tired this way but so one
issue is the state space is too big
another one is that the ground truth
probably would be wrong it's not because
you're a professional player that you
will play the best move every time right
every player has their own strategy so
the ground truth where we're having here
is not necessarily true and our network
might might not be able to beat these
human players what we're looking into
here is an algorithm that beats humans
okay second one to many states in the
game as you mentioned and third one we
will likely not generalize the reason we
will not generalize is because in
classic supervised learning we're
looking for patterns if I ask you to
build an algorithm to detect cats versus
dogs it will look for what the pattern
of a cat is versus what the pattern of
the dog is in and the convolutional
filters we learn that in this case it's
about a strategy it's not about a
pattern so you have to understand the
process of winning this game in order to
make the next move you cannot generalize
if you don't understand this process of
long term strategy so we have to
incorporate that and that's where RL
comes into place
RL is reinforcement learning a method
that we could be described with one
sentence as automatically learning to
make good sequences of decision so it's
about the long term it's not about the
shorter and we would use it generally
when we have delayed labels like in this
game the label that you mentioned at the
beginning was probability of victory
this is a long term label we cannot get
this label now but over time the closer
we get to the end the better we have we
are at seeing the victory or not and
it's for to make sequences of decision
so we make a move then the opponent
makes a move then we make another move
and all the decisions of these move are
correlated with each other like you have
to plan in advance when you're human you
do that when you play chess when you
play go so examples of RL applications
can be robotics and it's still a
research topic how deep RL can change
robotics but thinking about having a
robot walking from here and you want to
send it there you want to send the robot
there what you're teaching the robot is
if you get there it's good right it's
good you achieve the task but I cannot
give you the probability of getting
there at every point I can help you out
by giving you a reward when you arrive
there and let you trial and error so the
robot will try and randomly initialize
the robot we just fall down at the first
at first gets a negative reward then
repeats this time the robot knows that
it shouldn't fall down it shouldn't go
down you should probably go this way so
true trial in there and reward on the
long term the the robot is supposed to
learn this pattern
another one is games and that's the one
we will see today games can be
represented as as a set of reward for
reinforcement learning algorithm so this
is where you win this is where you lose
let the algorithm play and figure out
what winning means and what losing means
until it learns okay the problem with
using deep learning is that the
algorithm will not learn because this
reward is to long term so we're using
reinforcement learning and finally
advertisement so a lot of advertisements
are real time bidding so you want to
know given a budget when you want to
invest this budget and this is a long
term strategy planning as well that
reinforcement learning
can help with okay so this was the
motivation of reinforcement learning
we're going to jump to a concrete
example that is a super vanilla example
to understand cue learning so let's
start with this game or environment so
we call that an environment generally
and it has several states in this case
five states so we have these states and
we can define rewards which are the
following so let's see what is our goal
in this game we define it as maximize
the return or the reward on the
long-term and what is the reward is the
numbers that you have here that were
defined by a human so this is where the
human defines the reward now what's the
game the game has five states state one
is a trash can and has a reward of plus
two state two is a starting state
initial state and we assumed that we
would start in the initial state with
the plastic bottle in our hand the goal
will be to throw this plastic bottle in
a can if it's the trash can we get plus
two if we get to state five we get to
the recycle bin and we can get plus ten
super important application state four
has a chocolate so what happens is if
you go to state four you get a reward of
one because you can eat the chocolate
and you can also through the the
chocolate in the in the in the recycle
bin hopefully that's the setting makes
sense so these states are of three types
one is the starting state initial which
is brown the normal state which is not
starting neither neither starting nor an
ending state and it's gray and the blue
states are terminal states so if we get
to the terminal state we end up a game
or an episode let's say that's the
setting make sense okay and here two
possible actions you have to move either
you go on the left or you go on the
right an additional rule will we'll add
is that the garbage collector will come
in three minutes
and every step takes you one minute so
you cannot spend more than three minutes
in this game in other words you cannot
stay at the chocolate and it
chocolate forever you have to move at
some point okay so one question I have
is how do you define the long-term
return because we said we want a
long-term return we don't want we don't
care about short-term returns what do
you think is a good way to define a
long-term return here yeah the sum of
the terminal states the sum of how many
points you have when you reach the
terminal stage so let's say I'm in state
2 I have 0 reward right now if I reach
the terminal state on the run on the on
your left the plus 2 I get plus 2 reward
and I finish the game if I go on the
right instead and I reach the plus 10
you're saying that the long-term return
can be all the sum of the rewards I got
to get there so plus 11 so this is one
way to define the long term return any
other ideas we probably want to
incorporate the time steps and reduce
the reward as as time passes and in fact
this would be called a discounted return
versus what you said would be called a
return here we use a discounted return
in and it has several advantages some
are mathematical because the return you
described which is not discounted might
not converge it might go up to plus
infinity this discounted return will
converge with an appropriate discount so
intuitively also why is the discounted
return intuitive is it's because time is
always an important factor in our
decision making people prefer cash now
than cash in 10 years right or similarly
you can consider that the robot has a
limited life expectancy like it has a
battery and loses battery every time it
moves so you want to take into account
this disk
of if I can eat chocolates close I go
for it because I know that the chocolate
is too far I might not get there because
I'm losing some battery some energy for
example so this is the discounted return
now if we take gamma equals 1 which
means we have no discounts the best
strategy to follow in this setting seems
to be to go to the to the left to go to
the right starting in the initial state
- right and the reason is it's a simple
computation on one side I get plus 2 on
the other side I get plus 11 what if my
discount was point 1 which one will be
better
yeah the left would be better directly
to plus and the reason is because we
compute in our mind we just do zero plus
0.1 times Mount one which gives us 0.1
plus 0.1 squared times 10 and it's less
than two we know it okay so now we're
going to assume that the discount is 0.9
and it's a very common discount to to to
to to use in reinforcement learning and
we use a discount a traitor
so the general question here and it's
the core of reinforcement learning in
this case of cue learning is what do we
want to learn and this is really really
think of it as a human what would you
like to learn what are the numbers you
need to have in order to be able to make
decisions really quickly assuming you
had a lot more states than that in
actions
any ideas of what we want to learn
what would help our decision-making
optimal action at each state yeah that's
exactly what we want to learn for given
States tell me the action that I can
take and for that I need to have a score
for all the actions in every state in
order to store these scores we need a
matrix right so this is our matrix we
will call it a cue table it's going to
be of shape number of states times
number of actions if I have these matrix
of scores and the scores are correct I'm
in state three I can look on the third
row of this matrix and look what's the
maximum value I have is it the first one
or the second one if it's the first one
I go to the left if it's the second one
that is maximum I go to the right this
is what we would like to have does that
make sense
this Q table so now let's try to build
the Q table for this example if you have
to build it you would first think of it
as a tree oh and by the way every entry
of this Q table tells you how good it is
to take this action in that state state
corresponding to the row action
corresponding to the color so now how do
we get there we can build a tree and
that's that's similar to what we would
do in our mind we start in s2 in s2 we
have two options either we go to s1 we
get to or we go to s3 and we get zero
from s2 week from s1 we cannot go
anywhere it's a terminal state but from
s3 we can go to s2 and get zero by going
back or we can go to s4 and get one that
make sense from s4 same we can get zero
by going back to s3 or we can go to s5
and yet plus 10 now here I just have my
immediate reward for every state what I
would like to compute is the discounted
returned for all the states because
ultimately what should lead my
decision-making in a state is if I take
this action I get two new States what's
the maximum reward I can get from there
in the future
not just the reward I get in that state
if I take the other action I get to
another state what's the maximum reward
I could get from that state not just the
immediate reward that I get from going
to that state so what we would do we can
do it together let's say we want to
compute the value of of the actions from
s3 from s3 going right and left from s3
I can either go to s4 or s2 going to s4
I know that the immediate reward was 1
and I know that from s4 I can get +10
this is a maximum I can get so I can
discount this 10 multiplied by 0.9 10
times 0.9 Jesus 9 plus 1 which was the
immediate reward is just 9 Jesus means
10 so 10 is the score that we give to
the action go right from state s3 now
what if we do it from one step before s2
from s2 I know that I can go to s3 + 2 s
3 I get 0 reward so the immediate reward
is 0 but I know that from s3 I can get
10 reward ultimately on the long-term I
need to discount this reward from one
step so I multiply this 10 by 0.9 and I
get 0 plus 0.9 times 10 which gives me 9
so now instead two going right will give
us a long-term reward of 9 make sense
and you do the same thing you can copy
back that going from s4 to s3 will give
you 0 plus the maximum you can get from
s3 which was 10 discounted by point 9 or
you can do it from s2 from s2 I can go
left and get +2 or I can go right and
get 9 and the immediate reward would be
9 would be 0 and I will discount the 9
by 0.9 and get 8.1 so that's the process
we would do to compute that and you see
that it's an iterative algorithm you
will just copy back all these values in
my matrix and now if I'm in state 2 I
can clearly say that the best action
seems to go seems to say go to the left
because the long-term discounted reward
is 9 while the long-term discounted
reward for going to the right is 2
and I'm done that's to learning I solved
the problem I had I had a stay a problem
statement
I found a matrix that tells me in every
state what action I should take I'm fine
so why do we need deep learning it's a
question we will try to answer so the
best strategy to follow with point nine
is still right right right and the way I
see it is I just look at my matrix at
every step and I follow always the
maximum of my row so from state to nine
is the maximum so I go right from state
310 is the maximum so I still go right
and from state 410 is the maximum so I
go right again so I take the maximum
over all the actions in a specific state
okay now one interesting thing to follow
is that when you do this iterative
algorithm at some point it should
converge and ours converged to some
values that represent the discounted
rewards for every state and action there
is an equation that this Q function
follows and we know that the optimal Q
function followed this equation the one
we have here follows this equation this
equation is called the bellman equation
and it has two terms one is R and one is
this count times the maximum of the Q
scores over all the actions so how does
that make sense given that you know
state s you want to know the score of
going of taking action a in this state
the score should be the reward that you
get by going there plus the discount
times the maximum you can get in the
future that's actually what we used in
the iteration does this bellman equation
make sense okay so remember this is
going to be very important in to
learning this bellman equation
it's the equation that is satisfied by
the optimal Q table or Q function and if
you try out all these entries you will
see that it follows this equation
so when she didn't is not optimal it's
not following this equation yet we would
like you to follow this equation another
point of vocabulary reinforcement
learning is a policy policies denoted P
sometimes or new and sorry pi PI of s is
equal to arc max over the actions of the
optimal Q not sure what it means it
means it's exactly our decision process
it's even that we're in state s we look
at all the columns of this state s in
our Q table we take the maximum and this
is what PI of S is telling us it's
telling us this is the action you should
take so PI our policy is our
decision-making okay it tells us what's
the best strategy to follow in a given
state any questions so far
ok and so I have a question for you
why is deep earning helpful yes that's
very Z number of states is way too large
to store a table like that like if you
have a small number of states and number
of actions then easy you can use a few
table you can add every state look into
the key table it's super quick and find
out what you should do but ultimately
this Q table will get bigger and bigger
depending on the application right and
the number of states for go is 10 to the
power 170 approximately which means that
this matrix should have a number of rows
equal to 10 with 170 zeros after you
know what I mean it's very big and
number of actions is also going to be
bigger and go you can place your action
everywhere on the board that is
available of course okay so many way to
many states and actions so we would need
to come up with maybe a function
approximator
that can give us the action based on the
state instead of having to store this
matrix that's where deep learning will
come
so just to recap this first 30 minutes
in terms of vocabulary we learn what an
environment is it's the it's the general
game definition an agent is the thing
we're trying to train the decision-maker
a state an action reward Total Return a
discount factor the cue table which is
the matrix of entries representing how
good it is to take action a in state s a
policy which is our decision making
function telling us what's the best
strategy to apply in a state and Batman
equation which is satisfied by the
optimal cue table now we will tweak this
cue table into a cue function and that's
where we shift from cue learning to deep
cue learning so find a cue function to
replace the few table ok so this is the
setting we have our problem statement we
have our cue table we want to change it
into a function approximator that will
be our neural network does that make
sense how deep learning comes into
reinforcement learning here so now we
take a state as input for word
propagated in the deep network and get
an output which is an action an action
score for all the actions it makes sense
to have an output layer that is the size
of the number of actions because we
don't want to we don't want to give an
action as input and the state as input
and get the score for this action taken
in this state instead we can be much
quicker you can just give the state as
input get all the distribution of scores
over the output and we just select the
maximum of this vector which will tell
us which action is best so if I wait for
in states to let's say here we're in
state two and before propagate state 2
we get two values which are the scores
of going left and right from state two
we can select the maximum of those and
it will give us our action
the question is how to train this
network we know how to train it we've
been learning it for nine weeks compute
the loss back propagate can you guys
think of some issues that that make this
setting different from a classic
supervised learning setting the reward
changes dynamically so the reward
doesn't change the reward is set you
define it at the beginning it doesn't
change that m'kay but I think what you
meant is that the Q score is changed
dynamically that's true the Q scores
change dynamically but that's that's
probably okay because our network
changed that our network is now the Q
score so when we update the parameters
of the network it updates the Q scores
what's what's another issue that we
might have No Labels
remember in supervised learning you need
labels to train your network what are
the labels here and don't say compute
the Q table use them as labels it's not
gonna work okay
so that's the main issue that makes this
problem very different from classic
supervised learning so let's see how how
deep burning can be tweaked a little and
we want you to see these techniques
because they're helpful when you read a
variety of research papers we have our
network given a state gives us two
scores that represent actions for going
left and right from these states the
last function that will define is it a
classification problem or a regression
problem regression problem because the Q
score doesn't have to be a probably B to
the 0 & 1 it's just a score that you
want to give and that should look that
should mimic the long term discounted
reward so in fact the last function we
can use is is the L to last function y
minus the Q score squared so let's say
we do it for the Q going to the right
the question is what is why what is the
target for this queue and remember what
I copied on the top of this slide is the
bellman equation we know that the
optimal queue should follow this
equation we know it the problem is that
this equation depends on its own Q you
know like you have to on both sides of
the equation it means if you set the
label to be R plus gamma times max of Q
stars then when you will back propagate
you will also have a derivative here let
me let me go into the details let's
define the target value let's assume
that going left is better than going
right at this point in time so we
initialize the network randomly we
forward propagate state to in the
network and the Q score for left is more
than the Q score for right so that's the
action we will take at this point is
going left let's define our target Y as
the reward you get when you go left
immediate plus gamma times the maximum
of all the Q values you get from the
next step so let me spend a little more
time on that because it's a little
complicated
I mean s I move to s next using a move
on the left I get immediate reward R and
I also get a new state s prime s next I
can for propagate this state in the
network and you understand what is the
maximum I can get from this state take
the maximum value and plug it in here so
this is hopefully what's the optimal Q
should follow it's a proxy to a good
label it means we know that the bellman
equation tells us the best q satisfies
this equation when in fact this equation
is not true yet because the true
equation will have Q star here not q q
star which is the optimal q what we hope
is that if we use this proxy as our
label and we learn the difference
between where we are now and this proxy
we can then update the proxy get closer
to the optimality train again update the
proxy get closer to optimality train
again and so on our only hope is that
this will converge so does it make sense
how this is different from the burning
the labels are moving they're not static
labels we define a label to be a best
guess of what would be the best few
function we have then we compute the
loss of where the Q function is right
now compared to this we back propagate
so that the Q function gets closer to
our best guess then now that we have a
better q function we can have a better
guess so we make a better guess and we
fix this guess and now we compute the
difference between this Q function that
we have and our best guess we back
propagate up we get to our best guess we
can update our best guess again and we
hope that doing that iteratively will
end with the convergence and a q
function that will be very close to
satisfy the bellman equation the optimal
penguin equation does it make sense this
is the most complicated part of Q
learning yeah we generate the output of
the network we get two Q function we
compare it to the q the best q function
that we think is the one that satisfies
the bellman equation we don't but we
guess it based on the Q we have so
basically when you have Q you can
compute this Batman equation and it will
give you some values these values are
probably closer to where you want to get
to where from where you are now where
your now is is further from this
optimality and you want to reduce this
gap by by like to close the gap you back
propagate yes so the question is is
there possibility for this to diverge so
this is a broader discussion that would
take a full lecture to prove so I put a
paper here from for Francisco Melo which
proves the convergence of this algorithm
so it converges and in fact
it converges because we're using a lot
of tips and tricks that we will see
later but if you want to see the math
behind it and it's a it's a full lecture
of proof I invite you to look at this
simple proof for convergence of
development equation ok ok so this is
the case where a Left score is higher
than right score and we have two terms
in our targets immediate reward for
taking action left and also discounted
maximum future reward when you are in
state it's as next ok the tricky part is
that let's say we we compute that we can
do it we have everything we have
everything to compute our target we have
R which is defined by the by the human
at the beginning and we can also get
this number
because we know that if we take action
left we can then get s next and we for
propagate ethnics in the network we take
the maximum output and it's this so we
have everything in this in this equation
the problem now is if I plug this and my
Q score in my loss function and I ask
you to back propagate back propagation
is what W equals W minus alpha times the
derivative of the last function with
respect to W the parameters of the
network which term will have a nonzero
value obviously the second term Q of s
go to the left will have a nonzero value
because it depends on the parameters of
the network W but Y will also have a
nonzero value because you have Q here so
how do you handle that you actually get
a feedback loop in this back propagation
that makes the network unstable what we
do is that we consider this fixed we
will consider this Q fixed the Q that is
our target is going to be fixed for many
iteration let's say a million or a
hundred thousand iteration until we get
close to there and our gradient is small
then we will update it and we'll fix it
so we actually have two networks in
parallel one that is fixed and one that
is not fixed
okay and the second case is similar if
the cue score to go on the right was
more than the Q score to go on the left
we would define our target as immediate
reward of going to the right plus gamma
times the maximum Q score we get if
we're in the states that we in the next
state and take the best action does this
make sense is the most complicated part
of Q learning
this is the hard part to understand so
immediate reward to go to the right and
discounted maximum feature reward when
you're in state s next going to draw it
so this is hold fix for backdrop so no
derivative if we do that then no problem
Y is just a number
we come back to our original supervised
learning setting y is the number and we
compute the loss and we back propagate
no difference okay
so compute DL over DW and update W using
stochastic gradient descent method
rmsprop Adam whatever you guys want so
let's go over this this full dqn deep Q
network implementation and this slide is
a pseudocode to help you understand how
this entire algorithm work we will
actually plug in many methods in this in
this pseudocode so please focus right
now and if you understand this you
understand the entire rest of the
lecture we initialize our two network
parameters just as we initialize the
network in deep learning we loop over
episode so let's define an episode to be
one game like going from start to end to
a terminal state this is one episode we
can also define episodes sometimes to be
many states like breakout which is the
game with the paddle usually is 20
points the first player to get 20 points
finishes the game so episode will be 20
points once you're looking over episode
starts from an initial state s in our
case it's only one initial state which
is state two and loop over time steps
for propagate S state two in the Q
network
execute action a which has the maximum Q
score observe a immediate reward R and
the next step s prime compute target Y
and to compute Y we know that we need to
take s prime for propagated in the
network again and then compute the last
function update the parameters will
gradually set does this loop make sense
it's very close to what we do in general
the only difference would be this part
like we compute target Y using a double
for propagation so we for a propagation
before propagate two times in each loop
do you guys have any questions on on
this pseudocode
okay so we will now see a concrete
application of a Dipsy network so this
was the theoretical partner we're going
to the practical part which is going be
to be more fun so let's look at this
game it's called breakout the goal when
you play breakout is to destroy all the
bricks without having the ball pass the
line on the bottle so we have a paddle
and our decisions can be idle stay stay
where you are move the paddle to the
right or move the paddle to the left
right and this demo and you have the
credits on the bottom of the slide shows
that after training breakout using Q
learning they get a super intelligent
agents which figures out the trick to
finish the game very quickly so actually
even like good players you don't know
this trick professional players no
district but in breakout you can
actually try to dig a tunnel to get on
the other side of the bricks and then
you will destroy all the bricks super
quickly from top to bottom instead of
bottom up what's super interesting is
that the network figured out this on its
own without human supervision and this
is the kind of thing we want to remember
if we were to use input the go board and
output professional players we will not
figure out that type of stuff most of
the time so my question is what's the
input of the Q network in this setting
our goal is to destroy all the bricks so
play break out what should be the input
try something that position position of
bricks position of the paddle function
of the bricks what else ball position
okay yeah I agree
so this is what we would call a future
representation it means when you're in
an environment you can extract some
features right and these are examples of
features give me the position of the
ball is one feature give me the position
of the bricks
another feature give me the position of
the paddle another feature which are
good features for this game but if you
want to get the entire information you'd
better do something else yeah the pixels
you don't want any human supervision you
don't want to put features you just okay
take the pixels play the game you can
control the paddle take the pixel so
yeah this is a good input to the cue
Network what's the output I said it
earlier probably the output of the
network will be three key values
representing the action going left going
right and staying idle in a specific
state that is the input of the network
so give it a pixel image we want to
predict choose scores for the three
possible actions now what's the issue
with that you think that would work or
not
can someone think of something going
wrong here looking at the inputs
okay I'm gonna help you
if I give ya you won't try oh yeah good
point based on this image you cannot
know if the ball is going up or down so
actually it's super hard because the
action you take highly depends on if the
goal is going up or down right
if the ball is going down and even if
the ball is going down you don't even
know which direct direction is going
down so there's a problem here
definitely there is not enough
information to make a decision on the
action to take and if it's hard for us
it's going to be hard for the network so
what's a hack - to prevent that it's to
take successive frames so instead of one
frame we can take four frames successive
frames and here the same setting as we
had before but we see that the ball is
going up we seed which direction is
going up and we know what action we
should take because we know the slope of
the ball and also also if it's going up
or down that make sense okay so this is
called a pre-processing given a state
computer function Phi of s that gives
you the history of this state which is
the four sequence of four last frames
what other pre-processing can we do and
this is something I want you to be quick
like we we learnt it together in deep
learning input pre-processing remember
the second lecture where the question
was what resolution should we use
remember you have a cat recon mission
what's resolution would you want to use
here same thing if we can reduce the
size of the input let's do it if we
don't need all that information let's do
it for example do you think the colors
are important very minor I don't think
they're important
so maybe we can grayscale everything
that removes three chat that converse
three channels into one channel which is
amazing in terms of computation what
else I think we can crop a lot of
this like maybe there's a line here we
don't need to make any decision we don't
need this course
maybe so actually there are some games
where the score is important for a
decision making an example is football
like or soccer when you're when you're
winning 1-0 you you'd better if you're
playing against the strong team defend
like get back and defend to keep this
one zero so the score is actually
important in the decision-making process
and in fact their famous coach in
football which have this technique
called park the bus where you just put
all your team in front of the goal once
you have scored a goal so this is an
example so here there is no park the bus
but we can definitely get rid of the
score which remove some pixels and
reduces the number of computations and
we can reduce to grayscale one important
thing to be careful about when you
reduce your grayscale is that grayscale
is a dimensionality reduction technique
it means you you lose information but
you know if you have three channels and
you reduce everything in one channel
sometimes you would have different color
pixels which will end up with the same
grayscale value depending on the grade
scale that we use and it's been seen
that you lose some information sometimes
so let's say the ball and some bricks
have the same grayscale value then you
would not differentiate them or let's
say the paddle and the background have
the same grayscale value then you would
not differentiate them so you have to be
careful of that type of stuff and
there's other methods that do greyscale
in not other ways like luminance so we
have our Phi of s which is this which is
this input to the key network and the
dip to network architecture is going to
be a convolutional neural network
because we're working with images so we
for propagate dots this is the
architecture from min cavusoglu
silver at all from the pine cone value
can't really control uu to fully
connected layers and you get your Q
scores and we get back to our training
loop so what do we need to change in our
training loop here is we said that one
frame is not enough so we pre process
all the frames so
initial States is converted to 5s the
fault propagated state is 5s and so on
so everywhere we had s or s Prime we
convert to Phi of s or Phi of s prime
which gives us the history now there are
a lot more techniques that we can plug
in here and we will see three more one
is keeping track of the terminal state
in this loop we should keep track of the
terminal state because we said if we
reach a terminal state we want to end
the loop break the loop another reason
is because the Y function so basically
we have to add create a boolean to
detect the terminal States before
looping through the time steps and
inside the loop we want to check if the
new s Prime we're going to is a terminal
state if it's a terminal state then I
can stop this loop and go back play
another episode so play another start at
another starting state and continue my
game now this Y target that we compute
is different if we're in a terminal
state or not because if we're a terminal
state there is no reason to have a
discounted long-term reward there's
nothing behind that terminal state so if
we're in terminal state we just set it
to the immediate reward and we break if
we're not in a terminal state then we
would add this discounted future reward
any questions on that yep another issue
that we're seeing this and which makes
this reinforcement learning setting
super different from the classic
supervised learning setting is that we
only train on what we explore it means
I'm starting in a state s I compute I
forward propagate this Phi of s in my
network I get my vector of Q values I
select the best Q value the largest I
get a new state because I can move now
from state s to s prime so I have a
transition from s take action a get s
prime or Phi of s take action a get Phi
of s prime now this is what I will use
to train my network I can forward
propagate Phi of s prime again
the network and get my why targets
compare my why to my queue and then back
propagate the issue is I may never
explore this state transition again
maybe I will never get there anymore
it's super different from what we do in
supervised learning where you have a
data set and your data set can be used
many times with batch gradient descent
or with any gradient descent algorithm
one epoch you see all the data points so
if you do to epochs you see every day
two points two times if you do ten
epochs you see every day to prostrate
three times ten times so it means that
every data point can be used several
time to train your algorithm in classic
deep learning that we've seen together
in this case it doesn't seem possible
because we only train when we explore
and we might never get back there
especially because the training will be
influenced by where we go so maybe there
are some places where we will never go
because why we train and why we learn it
will it will kind of direct our decision
process and we will never train on some
parts of the game so this is why we have
other techniques to keep this training
stable one is called experience replay
so as I said here is what we are
currently doing we have Phi of s for
propagates get a from taking action a we
observe an immediate reward R and a new
state Phi of s Prime then from Phi of s
Prime we can take a new action a prime
observer a new reward R prime and the
new state Phi of s prime prime and so on
and each of these is called a state
transition and can be used to Train this
is one experience leads to one iteration
of gradient descent a 1 e 2 e 3
experience one experience to experience
tree and the training will be trained on
experience one then trained on
experience two then trained our
experience tree what we're doing with
experience replay is the following we
will observe experience one because we
start in a site we take an action we see
another state and earn a reward and this
is called experience one we will create
a replay memory you can think of it as a
data structure in computer science and
you will place this experience one topo
in the
your play memory then from there we will
experience experience - we will put
experience - in the replay memory same
with experience 3 put it in a replay
memory and so on
now during training what we will do is
we will first train on experience 1
because it's the only experience we have
so so far next step instead of training
on e 2 we will train on a sample from a
1 in we - it means we will take one out
of the replay memory and use this one
for training but we will still continue
to experiment something else and we will
sample from there and at every step the
replay memory will become bigger and
bigger and while we train we will not
necessarily train on the step we explore
we will train on a sample which is the
replay memory + the new state way we
explore why is it good is because e 1 as
you see can be useful many times in the
training and maybe one was a critical
state like it was a very important data
point to learn or q function and so on
and so on does the replay memory make
sense so several advantages one is data
efficiency we can use data many times
don't have to use one day to appoint
only one time another very important
advantage of experience replay is that
if you don't use experience replay you
have a lot of correlation between the
successive data points so let's say the
ball is on the bottom right here and the
ball is going to the top left for the
next 10 data points the ball is always
going to go to the top left and it means
the action you can take is always the
same it actually doesn't matter a lot
because the ball is going up but most
likely you want to followed where the
ball is going so the action will be to
go towards the ball for 10 actions in a
row and then the ball will bounce on the
wall and on the top and go back down
here down to the bottom left the bottom
right what will happen if your paddle is
here is that for 10 steps in a row you
will send your paddle on the right
remember what we said when which when we
asked the
question if you had to train a cat vs.
dog classifier with batches of images of
cats batches of images of dog trained
first on the cats then trains on the
dogs then trains on the cats then trains
on the dogs we will not converge because
your network will be super biased
towards predicting chat after seeing ten
images of cat super bias bit with
predicting dogs when it sees ten images
of dog that's what's happening here
so you want to deke or elate all these
experiences you want to be able to take
one experience take another one that has
nothing to do with it and so on this is
what experience pure play goes and the
third one is that the third one is that
you're basically trading computation and
memory against exploration exploration
is super costly the state space might be
super big but you know you have enough
computation probably you can have a lot
of competition and you have memory space
let's use an experience replay okay
so let's address experience replay to
our code here the transition resulting
from this part is added to the
experience to the replay memory D and
will not necessarily be used in the
iteration space so what's happening is
before propagate Phi of s we get we
observe a reward and an action and this
action leads to a state Phi of s prime
this is an experience instead of
training on this experience I'm just
going to take it put it in the replay
memory add experience to replay memory
and what I will train on is not this
experience is a sample random mini batch
of transition from the replay memory so
you see we're exploring but we're not
training on what we explore we're
training on the replay memory but the
replay memory is dynamic it changes and
update using the sample transitions so
the sample transition from the replay
memory will be used to do the update
that's the hack now another hack we want
the last hack we want to talk about is
exploration versus exploitation so as a
human let's say you're commuting to
Stanford every day and you know the road
you're commuting yet you know it you
always take the same road and your bias
towards taking this road why because
the first time you took it it went well
and the more you take it the more you
learn about it not that it's good to
know the tricks of how to drive fast but
but like you know the tricks you know
that this this these slides is going to
be green at that moment and so on so you
you build a very good expertise in this
road super expert but maybe there's
another road that you don't want to try
that is better
you just don't try it because you're
focused on that road you're doing
exploitation you exploit what you
already know
exploration would be ok let's do it I'm
gonna try another road today I might get
late to the course but maybe I will have
a good discovery and I will like this
road and I will take it later on there's
a trade-off between these two because
the RL algorithm is going to figure out
some strategies that are super good and
we'll try to do local search in these to
get better and better but you might have
another minimum that is better than this
one and you don't explore it using the
algorithm which currently have there is
no trade-off between exploitation
exploration we are almost doing only
exploitation so how to incentivize this
exploration you guys have an idea
so right now when we're in a state as
we're for propagating the state process
states in the network and we take the
action that is the best action always so
we exploiting we're exploiting what we
already know we take the best action
instead of taking this best action what
can we do yep Monte Carlo sampling we
point another one you wanted to try
something else get out of her and there
that's the ratio times e take the best
action versus exploring another action
okay take a hyper parameter that tells
you when you can explore when you can
exploit that what you mean yeah that's a
good point so I think that's that's a
solution you can take a hyper parameter
that is a probability telling you with
this probability Explorer otherwise with
one - is this probability exploit that's
what that's what we're going to do
so let's look why exploration versus
exploitation doesn't work we're in
initial state 1 s 1 and we have three
options either we go using action a1 2 s
2 and we get reward of 0 or we go to
action use action to get to s 3 and get
reward of 1 or use action 3 and go to s
4 and get a reward of 1,000 so this is
obviously where we want to go we want to
go to s 4 because it has the maximum
reward and we don't need to do much
computation in our head it's simple
there is no discount it's direct just
after initializing the Q networks you
get the following Q values for
propagates s1 induction network and get
0.5 for taking action 1.4 for taking
action 2.3 for texting action 3 so this
is obviously not good but our networking
was randomly initialized what it's
telling us is that 0.5 is the maximum so
we should take action 1 so let's go take
action 1 observe s2 you observe a reward
of 0 our targets because it's a terminal
state is only equal to the reward there
is no additional term so we want our
target to match our queue our target is
0 so Q should match zero
so we train and we get the cue that
should be zero that make sense now we do
another round of iteration we look we're
in s1 we get back to the beginning of
the episode we see that our cue function
tells us that action 2 is the best
because point 4 is the maximum value it
means go to s3 I go to s3 I observe
reward of 1 what does it mean it's a
terminal state so my target is 1 y
equals 1 I want the cue to match my
white
so my Q should be 1 now I continue third
step up q function says go to a 2 I go
to a 2 nothing happens I already matched
the reward for step go to a 2 you see
what happens we will never go there we
will never get there because we're not
exploring so instead of doing that what
we're saying is that 5% of the time
take a random action to explore and 95%
of the time follow your exploitation ok
so that's where we add it we probably
see Epsilon the hyper parameter take
random action a otherwise do what we
were doing before exploit does that make
sense ok cool so now we plugged in all
these tricks in our pseudocode and this
is our new studio code so we have to
initialize the replay memory which we
didn't have to do earlier in blue you
can find the replay memory added lines
in orange you can find the added lines
for checking the terminal state and in
purple you can find the added line is
related to Epsilon greedy exploration
versus exploitation and finally in bold
the pre-processing
any questions on that so that that's
that's we wanted to see a variant of how
deep learning can be used in the setting
that is not necessarily classic
supervised learning setting
and you see that the main advantage of
deep learning in this case is it's a
good function approximator the
convolutional neural network can extract
a lot of information from the pixels
that we were not able to get with other
networks okay so let's let's see what we
have here we have our super battery but
that's gonna dig a tunnel and it's going
to destroy all the bricks super quickly
it's good to see that after building it
like so this is work from deep mines
team and you can find this video on
YouTube okay another thing I wanted to
say quickly is what's the difference
between weed and without human knowledge
you will see a lot of people a lot of
papers mentioning that this algorithm
was trained with human learned knowledge
or this algorithm was trained without
any human in the loop
why is human knowledge very important
like think about it just playing one
game as a human and teaching that the
algorithm will help the algorithm a lot
when the algorithm sees this game what
it sees its pixels what we see when we
see that game we see that there is a key
here we know the key is usually a good
thing so we have a lot of context right
as a human we know I'm probably gonna go
for the key I'm not gonna go for this
this thing no same ladder
what is the ladder we directly identify
that the ladder is something we can go
up and down we identified that this rope
is probably something I can use to jump
from one side to the other so as a human
there is a lot more background
information that we have even without
knowing it without realizing it so
there's a huge difference between
algorithms trained with
human-in-the-loop and without human in
the loop this game is actually Montezuma
revenge the dqn algorithm when the paper
came out on underneath on nature in
nature the second the second version of
the paper they showed that they beat
human on 49 games that are the same type
of games I as break out but this one was
the hardest one so they couldn't beat
human on this one and the reason was
because there's a lot of information and
also the game has is very long
so in order it's called Montezuma
revenge and I think ranting pyramids is
going to talk about it a little later
but in order to get to win this game you
have to go through a lot of different
stages and it's super long so it's super
hard for the algorithm to explore all
the state space okay so that said I will
show you a few more games that that the
deepmind team has solved pong is one
sequence is another one and space
invaders that you might know which which
is probably the most famous of the three
Juno okay so that said I'm gonna hand in
the microphone to we're lucky to have an
oral expert so Rammstein terawatts is a
fourth-year PhD students in RL working
with professor Bernstein at Stanford and
he will tell us a little bit about his
experience and he will show us some
advanced applications of deep learning
and RL and how these plug in together
thank you thanks Cal for that
introduction
oh yeah can everyone hear me now all
right good cool okay first I have like
eight nine minutes I have more okay okay
first question after seeing that lecture
so far look how many are you're thinking
that RL is actually cool look honestly
that's like oh that's a lot
oh yeah that's a lot okay my hope is
after showing you some other advanced
topics ears then the percentage got even
increase so let's let's see it's almost
impossible to talk about like
advancement RL like recently without
mentioning alphago
I think somewhere right now who wrote
that on a table that it's almost 10 to
the power 170 different configuration of
the board and that's roughly more than I
mean that's more than the estimated
number of atoms in the universe so one
traditional algorithm before the deep
learning and stuff like that was like
three searching RL which is basically go
exhaustively search all the
a possible action that you can take and
they'll take the best one in that
situation also good that's all almost
impossible so what they do that's also a
paper from deep mind is that they train
anyone Ezra for that they kind of
marriage the tree search we do a bit
different and neural network that they
have they have two kinds of networks one
is called value network and value
network is basically consuming this
image image of a board and telling you
what's the probability that if you can
win in this situation so if the value is
higher than the probability of winning
is higher how does it help you he help
you in the case that if you want to
search for the action you don't have to
go until the end of the game because the
end of the game is a lot of steps and
it's almost impossible to go to the end
of the game in all the simulations so
that just helps you to understand what's
the value of each game like beforehand
like after look for these simple 50s
that if you're gonna win that game or if
you're gonna lose that game there's
another a network of the policy Network
which helps you to take action but I
think the most interesting thing of the
Alpha goal is that it's trained from
scratch so it's trance from nothing and
if they have a tree called self play
that there is two AI playing with each
other the best one I replicate the best
the best one I can keep it fixed and I
have another one that is trying to cop
beat the previous version of itself and
after it complete the previous version
of itself like you reliably many times
then I replace this again for the
previous part and then I just said so
this is a training curve of like a self
a self play of the alphago as you see
and it takes a lot of compute so that's
kind of crazy but finally they beat the
human okay another type of algorithm but
this is like the whole different class
of algorithm called a policy gradients
I've developed an algorithm called trust
region policy yeah can I stop the this
method residual during locomotion
controllers procedure can you use this
out please
okay great so policy gated algorithm
but I can do is that it stop this from
here that is not episode work okay so
here like in the diction that you have
seen you you came and like compute a Q
value of HS state and then what you have
done is that you take the arc max of
this with respect to action and then you
choose the action that you want to
choose right but what care at the end of
the day is the action which is the
mapping from a state to action which if
we call it a policy right so what you
can at the end of the day is actually
the policy like what action should I
take is not really Q value itself right
so this clatters a class of methods that
call the policy gradients is trying to
directly optimize for the policy so
rather than updating the Q function I
compute the gradient of my policy I
update my policy network again and again
and again so let's see these videos so
this is like this guy that is trying to
reach the pink ball over there and
sometimes that gets hit by the some
external forces and if it's called the
algorithm product EPO obviously policy
gradient and try to reach to that ball
so I think that you've heard of open a I
like five like the but that is putting
dota so this is like completely like PPO
algorithm and they have like a lot of
compute to showing that and I guess I
have the numbers here there is like 180
years of play in one day this is how
much code could be so that's why there
is another even funnier video right
again the same idea it's conjugate yet
is that you put two asian in front of
each other and they try to beat each
other and if they beat each other they
give everyone their the most interesting
part is that for example in that game
the purpose is just to pull the other
one out right but they understand some
emerging behave
yeah which is it for us human makes
sense but for them to learn out of
nothing is kind of cool so there's like
one risk here that when they're playing
okay this guy's trying to kick the ball
inside but one risk here is to overfit
that's also cool again by technical
point before move but I got 28 is that
here but where is that not the next one
okay here that - OH - agent playing with
each other and we are just updating the
person with the best other agent
previously we are doing a self play is
that you over fit to the actual agent
that you're in front of you so the agent
in front of you is powerful but you
might over fit to this and if I put the
agent that is not that powerful but is
using a simple trick that the powerful
agent that can never use this then you
might just lose the game right so one
trick here to make it more stable is
that rather than playing against only
one agent you alternate between
different version of the agent itself so
it all like learns all the skill
together it doesn't over fit to the
stuff so there's another thing conduct
meta learning meta learning is a whole
different algorithms again and the
purpose is that a lot of tasks are like
similar to each other right the core
example of watching two left and working
- right and like working in the front
direction they're like same test
essentially so the point is rather than
training on a single test which is like
go left or go right you train a
distribution of tests that are similar
to each other and then the idea is that
for each a specific task I should learn
bit like a very few gradient step so
very few updates should be enough for me
so if I learn okay play this videos like
at the beginning this agent that has
been trained with metal
before it doesn't know how to move but
just look at the number of gradient
steps like after two or three guillotine
steps
it totally knows how to move that's that
normally takes a lot of steps to train
but that's only because of the meta
learning approach that we've used here
meta learning is also cool I mean the
algorithm is from Brickley Chelsea Finn
which is not also coming to Stanford is
called model agnostic meta learning so
all right another point this very
interesting game Montezuma revenge that
young talk how much time they have yeah
so you've seen a exploration
exploitation dilemma right so it's it's
it's bad if you don't you're gonna fail
many times so if you do the exploration
scheme that you just saw that this is a
map of the particular game and you can
see call it things of that game if you
like exploration land of it and I think
has a twenty one or twenty something
different that it's hard to reach so
this recent paper anything from Google
brain for mark dilemma and team is
called
unifying the count based methods for
exploration exploration essentially very
hard challenge mostly in the situation
that the reward is a sparse for exactly
in this game but the first reward that
you get is when you reach the key right
from top to here it's almost like two
hundred steps and getting the number of
actuals after two hundred steps exactly
right but like a random exploration it's
almost impossible so you're never gonna
do that what a very interesting trick
here is that you kind of skip account on
how many times you visited a state and
then if you visit a state that is that
has like a few accounts then you give it
a revert to the agent so we call it the
intrinsic reward so it's kind of makes
the
so environment is also intensive ability
it has the instant tips to just go etc
because increase the counts of this
statement has never seen before so this
gets the nature tries to the experiment
so it just goes down visit like
different rooms like them so this game
is interesting if you certain people
that to solve the game is huge research
online
okay the highest of all of the game and
it's just fun also to see the agent play
[Music]
any question well right there is also
another interesting point that would be
just fun to know about is called
imitation learning imitation learning is
the case that well I mean RL agent so
sometimes you don't know the revoir like
for example in Atari games the revolt is
the key very well-defined right if I get
the key I get the reward that just
obvious but sometimes like defining the
reward is hard for example when the car
like the blue one wanna drive in a in
some high rail what is the definition of
the river right so we don't have a clear
definition of that but on the other hand
you have a person like you have human
expert that can drive for us and then we
see oh this is the right way of driving
right so in this situation we have
something called imitation learning that
we try to mimic the behavior of an
expert so not exactly copying this
because if we copy this and then you
show us it completely different states
that we don't know what to do but from
now we learn and this is like my example
and there's a paper that called
journal that the Soviet imitation
learning which was like from a Stefano's
group here at Stanford and that was also
interesting well I think that's advanced
topic if you have any questions I'm here
here
put yeah for next week so there's no
assignments you guys not finished
let's eat bye and you know about speak
like smuggles now project project these
partners get 2 turkeys as you know and
there is going to be the project team
mentorships in this Friday we have
connection with reading research papers
we go over the the object detection you
know and there will be two papers from
red mouse okay